quelqu'un qui arrive avec du coeur au
ventre
puis s'ils parlaient pas le français il
l'apprend picchi vis à vis au québec les
enfants se développe au québec comme moi
je les fais comme mes parents l'ont fait
est ce que c'est une menace ou un atout
mais pour moi ce n'est alors pas le
rodrigues le ministre fédéral avait son
mot à dire aujourd'hui parce que dans le
fond quand on parle d'immigration
plusieurs juste tourner vers ottawa
ottawa donnez-nous les pouvoirs et
c'était la réaction du ministre pablo
rodriguez sur le sujet de l'heure dans
notre campagne électorale et c'est ce
qu'on propose à nos thabeet kanza de
parler de ce sujet mais cinq invités
sinon j'allais barrettes de la caq
bonsoir monsieur georges barrère charles
robert du parti libéral bonsoir monsieur
robert est bienvenu guillaume tricherie
va de québec solidaire bonsoir stéphanie
stéphane handfield du parti québécois et
jacinthe eva réelle du parti
conservateur bonsoir à vous 5 bienvenue
c'est vraiment le sujet de l' on s'y
attendait fort monsieur je n'ai barrett
ont entendu avec sébastien tout à
l'heure les différentes déclarations de
monsieur legault sur le sens que doit
avoir l'immigration qui a parlé de
cohésion nationale mais aussi par les
deux clans de faction comme on voit aux
états unis tout ça ça provoque une
réaction vive des partis d'opposition
c'est une vision négative de
l'immigration
non pas du tout écoutez c'est une vision
positive ils nous ont gouvernement le
toujours prêter de façon positive
migration parce que on a investi des
sommes majeurs depuis tourné l'an 2018 à
l'époque deux minutes et demie ration
justement pour bien intégrer pour
franciser pour offrir l'accompagnement
aux personnes immigrantes et c'est ce
qu'on va continuer à faire notre plus
grand défi madame tussauds et c'est ce
que les autres formations politiques ne
voient pas c'est l'intégration en
français des personnes migrantes en la
loi 96 si ce qu'on a fait on s'est donné
les outils véritablement pour avoir les
moyens de bien française et de bien
intégrer les personnes gagnent parce que
le défi culinaire où nous avons c'est le
taux de soumission linguistique soit
c'est le taux de transfert linguistique
ça suffit de signifie quelle langue est
ce que les personnes migrantes
choisissent tel d'avoir comme langue
commune et ça doit être le français
malheureusement depuis 15 ans 20 ans
dans l'âme ils sont les personnes
migrantes choisissent une autre langue
que le français s'intègre dans une autre
langue il faut réussir comme a sion
comme société si on veut continuer de
parler français sont vus contraints de
vivre en france au québec de déployer
tous les efforts pour en intégrer en
français les personnes gardent et je
vous dirai pour le gouvernement fédéral
il devrait par leurs parents matière de
langue française lorsqu'ils n'ont pas
fait avec le dernier projet de madame
petit protégé alors monsieur gerry barr
est au gouvernement la cible de ces
cinquante mille par anis a été dépassé
peut-être à cause de pandémie l'appui 2d
tout sommet ouest ulm sur robert oui en
fait si robert breer lamine sow et
désirez simplement vous dire au cours
des deux dernières années il y aura
trois pages qui était fort beaux jours
des seuils d'immigration justement parce
que durant la pandémie on a appris que
très peu de personne ni graal concerne
la pénurie de main d'oeuvre c'est pour
ça que le seuil des 110 milles on
retourne à 50000 de l'année prochaine en
fonction de la capacité savez la société
québécoise est une des sociétés qui
accueille plus de personnes g c'est plus
que la france plus que les états unis
alors on est ouvert sur le monde mais il
faut intégrer en français les personnes
isolées et monsieur robert madame au
delà de citée par cbc mauvais a jugé que
la déclaration de monsieur le goût était
minable mais votre objectif vous c'est
70 mail est ce que ça tient compte de la
nécessité de vraiment intégré en france
est le plus grand nombre d'immigrants
bien sûr mais j'aimerais revenir un
petit peu sur la déclaration du ministre
alors que j'ai sincèrement qui est pas
beau à 140 kg
les ministres vient de dire à propos de
la déclaration du premier ministre qu'il
avait une vision positive de
l'immigration moi j'ai entendu le
premier ministre deux fois lié
l'immigration à une hausse potentielle
de la criminalité et lille i zal aux
folles les anglophones du québec où les
nouveaux québécois à un préjudice
potentiel
à la cohésion nationale alors je joue
visiblement là il semble avoir un fossé
en coups et lui quant à la perception de
ce que peut être la vie
migration policy alors les assauts votre
cible de 70 me et votre capacité
d'intégrer en français les immigrants si
tenté que vous avez à coeur le français
c'est un sous entendu ou dans une quête
elle sera bien ok c'est bien trop con
encore le français chez les libéraux les
libéraux les libéraux à travers
j'y reviendrai mais les libéraux quand
on était aux affaires évidemment vous le
savez on avait augmenté sensiblement les
enveloppes en francisation d'intégration
puis après la réforme suite au rapport
de la dg en 2017 on avait apporté
beaucoup de correctifs au processus de
francisation
alors aujourd'hui mais est de toute
façon je pense que tous les partis s'y
détendre et tous les partis s'ils ont à
coeur la défense du fait français en
amérique mais il ya un point est
néanmoins que je peux pas laisser passer
c'est que on est en campagne électorale
posez vous la question à savoir pourquoi
la cac quand vous tellement tellement
joué cette carte là et créer de la
polémique autour de cette question alors
monsieur je les fais affaire les trois
autres monsieur que free va réaliser
écoutez moi je préfère vous mettre de
l'avant nos positions et nos politiques
publiques nous on veut rétablir le
programme de l'expérience québécoise qui
est un programme destiné aux
francophones ou diplômés québécois ou
diplômé en fait issus de l'immigration
mais au québec à nos travers le transit
temporaire et on va accélérer aussi la
sélection des travailleurs en région on
va aussi avoir des programmes de
régularisation de statut on va accélérer
la réunification familiale bref une
vision positive humaines et les
poires actuel de l'immigration du tout à
fait et si les pouvoirs ne sont pas là
sont pour ça on va aller les chercher
vraiment québec solidaire on veut le
rapatriement totale des pouvoirs
l'immigration alors monsieur me suit les
joueurs c'est un avocat expert en
migrations vous avez un adversaire ou un
vis-à-vis dans une autre circonscription
monsieur une ville qui lui aussi est un
expert en profite ration monsieur de fil
vous saisit avec votre
votre vision de passe que vous aboutirez
free barça s'est renseigné ses 35 mais
techniquement alors le français élimine
gazon sont des sujets d'importance il
faut être en mesure d'en débattre de
façon sereine qui de façon positive
éviter de faire des amalgames alors nous
parti québécois évidemment on propose un
seuil d'une négation de 35000 pourquoi
parce qu'il faut savoir intégrer et
accueillir dignement et en 2022 bain et
lorsqu'on lui parlait de capacité
d'accueil de man et hôtelières compte
des ventes de places en cpe au tenir
compte de la crise du logement le manque
de médecins de famille évidemment le
manque d'enseignants alors il faut le
dire compte de ces facteurs et je pense
que leur celui de 35000 pour le parti
québécois c'est une proposition qui
crédible et c'est une propulsion surtout
qu'irresponsable dans les réponses et la
question quand allait déposer un
monsieur james a semblé le surprend s'il
ya de 50 mais certains ont estimé qu'ils
avaient sorti de son chapeau 5 en 2000
et en fait c'est ce qui est important
c'est un faux débat d'arriver avec des
obstinés sur des chiffres ce qui est
important c'est l'intégration et à ce
niveau là l'intégration des personnes
immigrantes la famille de favoriser la
reconnaissance des diplômes on échoue
lamentablement
notre bilan et notre solde migratoire au
québec est négatif depuis 1986 selon
l'institut de la statistique du québec
nos personnes immigrantes aa rivaux qui
arrivent au québec piette vers d'autres
provinces pour plusieurs raisons alors
c'est à ce qu'il faut s'attaquer d'abord
et avant tout ça passe par la
reconnaissance des diplômes étrangers là
dessus on échoue lamentablement au
québec ça passe aussi par un fort
leadership auprès du gouvernement
fédéral pour rapatrier des pouvoirs en
immigration ce que la caq a pas réussi à
faire dans les quatre dernières années
monsieur janin par êtes vous avez été
par le bon en fait ce sont vos séries
tout ça
les immigrants je vais vous laisser la
parole avec un extrait de monsieur
legault qu'on a peu entendu dans les
médias c'était par le devoir ce matin on
l'écoutera est en lien avec ce que les
autres disent on écoute mais va falloir
augmenter de 50% d'abord dans ce qu'on
contrôle au québec il faut d'abord
demander à ottawa pour partie contrôlée
par ottawa soin de nous donner poids
c'est ce qu'on préfère ou soit des plus
exigeants sur la connaissance du
français
suivez monsieur janin barrette c'était
une promesse phare du gouvernement
legault c'était de dire on veut tous les
pouvoirs en immigration sanaa le
monsieur legault nous dit ben on va
essayer d'avoir les pouvoirs mais si on
les a pas tous parce que déjà ottawa
vous ai dit non ben on va demander le
contrôle ou moins d'intégration en
france istres recul sud ne messieurs
général c'est pas du tout un recul
écoutez nous on est réaliste mais notre
plan d'action c'est vraiment de
rapatrier les pouvoirs matière de
regroupement familial
vous l'avez dit madame sous la position
du parlement est attaqué de toutes parts
par mes collègues partis rarement par le
cardinal robert à québec écoutez nous on
met de l'avant des propositions assez
pauvres ce qui a été dit que les
libéraux avaient investi massivement en
2014 2017 en migration au contraire ils
ont coupé est la ville qui a trait
général et éleveurs 2010 elle a dit
c'était lamentable au ministère de
l'immigration et dans le fond qui a
compté revue on a ramassé sur oumma
investisseurs sont 10 millions en
intégration en francisation donc voir
des points de service dans plus de
soixante régions au québec des antennes
pour mettre en place des conseillers en
immigration des agents d'adp à
l'intégration à l'accompagnement des
personnes migrantes pour que partout au
québec les personnes immigrantes se
sentent bien accueillis soit accompagnée
dès leur arrivée ceux ci n ont plus
grand défi aussi d'intégrer dans les
différentes régions du québec et vous
pouvez pas dire madame du soul qu'avec
le règne libéral en matière d'émigration
on a bien réussi à les intégrer les
personnes migrantes parce que il faut se
le dire lorsqu'une personne immigrante
arrivent au québec le halo faire un
choix difficile de quitter son pays de
quitter sa terre natale de quitter
parfois sa famille et on l'accueille au
québec mais il faut la soutenir la
compagnie c'est sûr qu'on a déployé
d'ailleurs les taux d'inscription aux
cours de francisation augmenter parce
qu'on a donné une allocation à temps
partiel on a bonifié la location à temps
plein pour permettre aux gens d'aller
suivre des cours de francisation nommé
également mis des frais de gamme pour
les parents lorsqu'ils vont justement
sur les cours de francisation alors et
on lover également aux immigrants papara
et les libéraux arrête pas de dire la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre on a beaucoup
d'immigrants qui songe contemporain mais
leur permettait pas d'aller suivre les
cours de français parce que ils
déployaient pas les ressources majeures
alors le gouvernement est fortement
conscientiser et on met l'argent et les
moyens nécessaires au point ma mission
c'était la première fois lors du budget
2010 neuf ans la miss oh que l'ensemble
enveloppe canada québec pour
l'intégration des personnes migrantes
était consacré au ministère de
l'immigration les libéraux russes qu'il
faisait il prenait largement voyais les
autres postes de dépenses de l'état
québécois mais prenez l'argent qu'il ya
des plaies mais je ne serai pas en
option avec une reprise us mont joli
buzz avec une fois vous avez pas des
demandes dont en matière d'immigration
de rapatrier tous les pouvoirs vous avez
demandé de fermer le chemin vague semble
hélas t'avoir may par 24 heures vous a
dit non alors qu'est ce que vous pensez
qu est ce que vous souhaitez faire
maintenant que tu as beau nous a dit non
sur le rapatriement des pouvoirs matière
d'immigration sur la fermeture des
frontières qu'est ce que vous allez
faire michel fils monsieur fils voulait
au parti québécois vous attendez le
grand soir pour faire des gains nous ce
qu'on veut faire la 4c qu'on a inscrit
dans la constitution noir sur blanc
l'existence même de la nation québécoise
et le fait que la nation québécoise elle
s'exprime en français les deux langues
françaises y avait aucun lien
concessionnels qui avait été fait par
votre formation politique au cours des
40 dernières années en matière qu'est ce
que c'est un vaincu lorsque le véhicule
au poids et n'agissent pas alors ce
qu'ils sont mais les positions et
lorsqu'elle est au gouvernement ils font
pas de gains dont la france est la loi
96 l'inscription dans la conscience
canadienne de l'existence humaine la
nation qui veut voir ça va donner des
outils juridiques marc au québec et
monsieur il le sait très bien les tables
alors oui si ça permettait je veux
laisser mon père
le discours du ministre est tellement
surréaliste et y est tellement nos
positions
avec les propos que le premier ministre
lui-même tenu alors si la coalition
avenir québec est aussi efficace en
matière d'intégration alors j'aimerais
comprendre pourquoi le premier ministre
tient des propos tellement divisif
tellement emprunt de plus un enjeu à la
mesure je peux pas accepter ce monsieur
je réponds pas vous plaît monsieur
j'allais partir on va laisser répondre
monsieur robert puis non je serais quand
même curieux d'entendre la réponse le
ministre
si vous acceptez de faire compris
monsieur problème
mais si j'avais brièvement parce que je
vais aller ensuite les prêts à madame
tussauds en termes comme le dit monsieur
robert de garage de boîte je pense que
c'est difficile à battre ce qu'ils
aiment femme également ce que madame en
éclats de fête aujourd'hui le premier
ministre lorsqu'il c'est le ce qui prime
dit très clairement qu'on doit
accueillir les personnes migrantes en
france entre les intégrer en français
est la démonstration que nous le faisons
c'est que nous avons consacré les sommes
et les budget nécessaire d'une façon
substantielle au cours des dernières
années ce que les libéraux n'ont pas
fait alors monsieur khabar aujourd'hui
le fait c'est lui conseillaient monsieur
couillard sur ses propos qui devait
tenir sur l'immigration il jugeait les
québécois il les prenait de haut en
disant qu'il soufflait sur les braises
de l'intolérance encore aujourd'hui le
poids de monsieur robert conseil madame
anglais et ça donne le même résultat
voyez-vous en
cela que je critique aujourd'hui c'est
vous c'est vous qui exacerbé la peur
chez les gens c'est vous qui exacerbé la
peur de l'autre le nous collectif que
vous vendent ils si nous mais pas avec
eux depuis quand vous parlez de madame
angot contre le souk au litige mais
permettez camusso la personne décision
du pape libéral y ont fait pendant 40
ans il disait écouter quand même voiture
à paris iv quoi il va avoir référendum
ça c'est de la politique de cohésion
nous on a 100 mais on ne te nouvelle
millions pour l'ensemble des québécois
je me suis tu laisses rivard parce que
c'est un référé monsieur robert et c'est
sur quoi il discute avec eux je me suis
géré barrette c'est la fameuse phrase de
monsieur legault il ya des plans d'aidé
faction voici aux états unis on voit ça
alors c'est ce qui est caisse provoqué
le tollé depuis hier moi je pense qu'il
ya personne qui ressort gagnant des
dernières minutes les yeux pour un
québécois et québécoises dans la maison
qui se dit ah oui quel débat inspirant
sur l'immigration moi je préfère mettre
de l'avant vision positive et inclusive
préfère qu'on parle ensemble quand on
demande de rapatrier les pouvoirs
certainement québec solidaire on est
tout à fait d'accord mais pour en faire
quoi le gouvernement khakis nous dit on
veut rapatrier des pouvoirs aux mains
familiales oui c'est quoi le programme
du regroupement familial quel est son
problème qu'est ce qu'on veut faire avec
on nous dit rien ou de locon la patrie
les pouvoirs est-ce qu'on veut rendre ça
plus compliqué pour les épouses pour les
conjoints pour les époux de rejoindre
leur sites web citoyen canadien leurs
époux québécois est ce qu on veut rendre
plus difficile pour les enfants
étrangers de venir rejoindre la famille
qu'est ce qu'on veut faire avec le
fameux programme de regroupement
familial
c'est quoi les questions c'est quoi les
propositions moi je certainement
d'accord qu'il faut les ramener mais
pour accélérer le traitement du
regroupement familial pour que des
enfants rejoignent leurs parents plus
rapidement ses seules les questions
qu'on doit poser au delà de rapatrier
les pouvoirs c'est pour en faire quoi et
ce jusqu'à jusqu'à ce jour c'est
silencieux du côté du grand dam allons
monsieur en fils
oui ben il prit j'ai entendu le candidat
libéral candidat de la cac et évidemment
à ccc du copier coller de ce qu'on a vu
aujourd'hui il faut voir aussi le débat
en matière d'immigration est proposé est
ce que le parti québécois propose c'est
une des propositions qui sont crédibles
qui sont responsables et qui évidemment
va faire en sorte qu'on va être capable
d'accueillir dignement et de franciser
également bois donc à nos candidats à
l'immigration parce que c'est ça
l'objectif on le boit ça ne fonctionne
pas monsieur barrette nous a dit que oui
l'a4 a fait des avancées en matière de
francisation et clés au niveau de
l'exigence du français pour les
candidats sélectionnés par québec pour
la liga sont économiques il avait été
moins exigeante est moins dur que ne
l'était le véhicule des poids alors
arrêtez de dire n'importe quoi et
regarder la réalité en face à l'accord
permet tait sur la caméra madame harel
sur la francisation il faut aussi savoir
qu'on n'a pas besoin d'une loi
contraignante comme la loi 96 pour
encourager la francisation je pense à
eau dans le comté par neuf les cours de
francisation sont disponibles seulement
à donnacona pour un territoire de 4000
m² pour 18 municipalités
alors il faut maintenant l'emphase sur
les cours de francisation monsieur
gergorin lui avait pu interpeller je
donnerais se montre confiant
bah écoutez faut régionaliser d'avantagé
l'immigration bien entendu et dans le
comté de portneuf il doit y avoir
davantage d'immigration c'est pour ça
qu'on a installé des antennes un peu
partout parce que justement dans les
gens québec accueille seulement 4% des
migrations qui verra ses seuls masse de
l'inconnu pour un territoire des 4000 de
mac
monsieur j'ai réparé dans la marelle ou
le savez comme moi quel point on
investit massivement d'un corps
d'immigration mais je suis content
d'avoir voté puis les petits mots c'est
sûr qu'on va se laisser tous les 5 merci
d'avoir fait partie de ce débat qui est
très chaud aujourd'hui versées à tous
les 5 et bonne fin de campagne 5 merci
au revoir c'est à vous madame mois pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit